i'm very pleased to say the transport
secretary grant shaps joins us once
again on the program good to see you mr
shaps do hope you've been well since the
last time we spoke um
i i wonder i wonder if we might start
this morning with with test and trace
um 37 billion pounds of taxpayers money
has been allocated to this system over
over two years
can can you justify that expenditure
yeah yeah it certainly hasn't been
cheap fighting coronavirus but it's
absolutely been necessary i mean this is
a quite strange
report 9.1 million 9.1 million
people have been connected uh uh
contacted
by tests and traces of people who
otherwise would be
wandering around often unaware that they
had coronavirus and
spreading it around further so whatever
the
you know coronavirus experience we've
had as a nation good and bad it would
have been one heck of a lot worse
if we didn't have a test and trace
system which has contacted
so many people uh and prevented the
disease from spreading
further i'm sure plenty of people will
see the logic in that perhaps not though
meg hilliard you know who correctly
identifies him and
we know this from internal department of
health and social care
documents we know that part of the point
of test and trace was of course to avoid
the second lockdown and we didn't
that's right but did we know that there
be the kent variant
b117 at that time no of course not did
we know it would be
70 percent more infectious unfortunately
we did not nor did anybody but you know
the truth is if we didn't have a test
and trace system if we hadn't contacted
those 9.1
million people this would have been one
heck of a lot worse
and and actually i i've heard a lot of
um odd things said actually now i think
about it about
testing trace over a period of time oh
they're not managing to connect
contact people and so on and so forth
well they can only do what
people enable them to do so if people
provide contact details it's obviously
much easier
but i've got the latest figure here for
example including
people whose contact details were not
given they still managed to contact in
total
93.3 of all contacts
so they've actually worked wonders they
managed to get hold of people even where
they didn't have the contact details
and that can only have prevented faster
and further spread
of this disease and therefore deaths as
well so thank goodness it's been there
um and as a dido uh just
said in in the report you just played um
we're
we are testing more per headed
population
uh than any other major economy in the
world and by a long way
you know two or three times over most
other countries
and again i i suspect that there will be
people watching this morning looking at
the numbers looking at how many people
have been tested
and and seeing a degree of validity in
your response
why then has meg helio and the public
accounts committee arrived at the
at such damning conclusions i mean we
know of course as well
from last october that sage were warning
about test and trace
i mean they said that they had only a
marginal impact on stopping the spread
of coronavirus that's the government's
scientists we've got the public accounts
committee we've had any number of
stories in the papers about the
the lack of efficacy to the scheme
well look i wouldn't want to pretend for
one moment it's been completely perfect
that'd be ridiculous and particularly in
the early days of course
it just didn't have the facility it
didn't have the scale this thing didn't
exist a year ago it's been put together
from nothing
something that even the select committee
uh itself says is very striking the
extent to which it's been built up but
let me put a different perspective on it
if i may not only is it as i say
carrying out all of these
tests and tracing all of these people
yesterday for example i think they're
over one and a half million
tests done and that's because as kids
are going back to
school and they're getting tested as
well again imagine if you weren't doing
that imagine if i wasn't testing
the hauliers the the lorry drivers um
going over to
the continent we wouldn't have been able
to reopen the border that was closed
uh just before christmas so to say that
the whole test and trace thing has
been a waste of time is is factually
untrue we wouldn't have goods flowing we
wouldn't have
medicines being imported because the
entire export import system would have
um frozen up
and then the the other very good example
of where it's worked is has been with
regards to these
variants uh i think i'm right in saying
the number of
variants from south africa has been
limited to 285
we know that because of test and trace
the number uh from brazil i think was
six
uh we know that because of test and
trace so it's been very successful in
doing things which otherwise would have
made would have meant that those
variants which are now the main concern
for us would have gotten out of control
so look i mean i didn't forget
we did have some difficulties finding
the sixth uh brazilian uh case of the
the brazilian variant but but just one
last point in this because obviously we
have much to talk about on your brief
a lot of people will look at and it's in
part you might think it's an unfair
comparison the one percent payoff
that has been made to nhs staff and the
2.7 million pounds being spent on
management consultants for test and
trace every day look everyone
understands there is there is a role for
consultancy
within any government people might
suggest that 3 million pounds a day is
just a little bit to true
yeah i mean look you can always look at
any budget and go why are you doing this
but you're not doing that or how are you
doing this bid but not that bit
i think um the nhs has had 60 billion
pounds more in the last year it's got
another 20 billion pounds
this year being spent on it because
we've got these extraordinary
extraordinary pressures um on the nhs
and without hesitation um this
government has provided everything the
nhs
needs to help get us through this um
through this pandemic i've seen it
firsthand
my dad's been in hospital and now
fortunately in rehab for
just over three months now including
having coronavirus in hospital during
that time
the nhs has been absolutely
extraordinary i've seen it firsthand um
i'm sure we can pick about uh pick apart
the budgets and say why this why not
that but
overall i i i just i i think the nhs has
performed phenomenally well
and been extraordinary over this period
i will do pass on our very best wishes
to your father i hope you get
back back to full speed um very soon
let's talk about the announcement from
the department for transport today you
know
millions of pounds being set aside
essentially to do some kind of
proprietary work for some for some quite
big projects and projects that i think
many people will see as
perhaps linked to to the future of the
union
well we certainly think it's a good idea
if you can get around the united kingdom
the union
and you can do so easily and what we've
done is some
in this interim report that's out today
um is identified a number of different
projects which
for whatever reasons aren't particularly
focused on
within each different constituent part
of the union in other words england
scotland wales and northern ireland but
actually
somebody needs to look at overall and
say ah this would help to make it easier
to travel from
for example northern ireland to england
which happens to be via road
called the a75 which is in scotland
that's never going to be a particular
priority for the scottish government but
actually it matters for connecting us
all together
making it easier for us to see our
friends and family and do business um
together so
that's the purpose of this connectivity
report uh the interim version which is
out today
another aspect of this which is which
has been quite quite widely trailed is
the
the potential cut to apd or passenger
duty
and obviously as transport secretary you
have a difficult balancing act on the
one hand
climate change one of the mantras of our
age on the other you want to get people
traveling again but but can you justify
essentially a
cut to apd which is encouraging people
to pollute yeah i mean first of all air
passenger duty was never introduced as a
sort of carbon um tax that's it's not
particularly designed
for that either so it's not it's not
terribly effective as a carbon tax there
are better ways to
to do that for example i want to see
sustainable aviation fuels
used in the uk which would remove carbon
um out of the system largely or indeed
entirely and we're already a pledge to
do that
we're going to get to zero carbon in in
aviation but what this is about today
again going back to the connectivity
uh you know traveling from from you know
literally
johnner growth to land's end is this
bizarre situation
where you pay less tax if you're flying
to
say london to barcelona than you do if
you're flying london to
edinburgh and which and back on the
return journey
which is a somewhat bizarre situation
and so what we've said today is we'll
carry out a consultation
we'll look at how we can do this more
fairly uh and we
will ensure that people aren't penalized
effectively for traveling within the
united kingdom which is what we're
talking about here
as opposed to paying less when you
travel abroad and come home which
does seem like it must be the wrong way
around we'll make sure overall
it doesn't collect any less tax the
system uh overall
um and uh and also making uh aviation
uh zero jet zero as we call it um
is is absolutely essential and we'll be
talking about that more
as part of this consultation as well um
uh
you will have i have had i'm sure them
some some bruising encounters with my
colleague on the breakfast wrote us
uh or previously my colleague on the
breakfast wrote is piers morgan you'll
have
noted you know he has this morning you
know
not apologized for what he said and
indeed has has stuck to his guns he has
i tweeted this morning i'm reliably
informed you know i continue to believe
that which i said which was of course
that he didn't believe meghan markle
when she spoke about her suicidal
thoughts i just wondered
what you made of that well uh putting
the issue
aside and of um what he was actually
talking about i'll miss the interviews
with with him i would have been doing
one in
and half an hour or whatever time i'm on
good morning britain this morning and
uh personally i always thought he he
gave a very tough but usually quite fair
interview and as with all interviewee
interviewers i was fine if you actually
answered the question
he tended to have an okay ride with it
which
which
was always uh you know i was trying to
go on and just if you didn't know the
answer just say
look i don't know or if you do know or
you know um
you you you give the facts um so uh
personally i'll miss him
uh on there uh i wasn't gonna get into
the details of the argument one way or
the other with regard to
uh uh megan though and that that's right
the different matter
uh why not i mean i'm sorry i mean you
know it's a yeah
a prominent broadcaster essentially said
on television that he did not believe
at someone when they spoke about their
mental health
now at a time of course when we're all
very preoccupied
with our own mental health be you a
royal or a commoner like myself
i i just wonder why you wouldn't speak
specifically to that
yeah first of all mental health is
incredibly
important and particularly during this
pandemic even more so
and there are two things here really
first of all there's a long-standing i
think very good convention that cabinet
ministers don't um sort of comment
on a royal um family matters like this
often to say i think we're very lucky to
have a queen who's um
it's uh her platinum jubilee next year
70 years
on the um throne but the rest of this
wider story
um i i know you will have discussed as
uh at length people who have seen the
interview they will have seen the
statement from the palace i don't think
it adds anything to have a cabinet
minister
uh get embroiled uh in that and then
secondly you're asking me not only to
judge that but to judge somebody else's
comments about it and that drags me
right into that into that territory
but on mental health itself um you will
have seen just this week
and the government's put i think another
70 million pounds into
addressing some of the very serious
mental health issues i think which
arise not least from this pandemic being
stuck at home
has been very very punishing physically
but also mentally
for people and i think recognizing the
stresses and strains of mental health
outside of that particular royal story
are very very important indeed